normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government
Atlanta antifa militants claim to have
torched concrete company trucks in
effort to stop cop City this is an
ongoing Terror campaign currently taking
place in Atlanta there have been 61
indictments but guess what as Julie
pointed out but as we're starting the
show these are state level and not
federal level so antifa is actively
engaged these are people who are part of
cells these are people who have come
from outside the country we know this
and they have cells all over the country
they they work with each other they
organize they have plans they have
workbooks and we are told consistently
the far R is the real threat I want to
add something in the previous segment we
were talking about the jury tax or the
trial tax where they forg people to take
ple plea uh plea Bargains dases was
pointing out that he can get you you
tell me about your life and he can point
out three felonies I want to tell you
guys something and then I want to open
the conversation up to January 6 and
your in your film the uh police state
on January 20th 2017 several hundred
far- leftists stormed through Washington
DC throwing uh Molotov cocktails uh uh
well I I should I should tone it down a
little bit setting fires in the street
torching vehicles smashing windows and
fighting with cops several hundred got
arrested I know I was one of those
people who got arrested I was released
after I asked a supervisor and I showed
him my press pass he told me too bad
you're under arrest you're not free to
go and then eventually a supervisor
ordered the relase of journalists of
which I was then un arrest de arrested
by the police I was never processed this
group was all of these people were
charged and guess what not only did most
of them have the charges dropped the
city paid them millions of dollars and
it was for one reason they all refused
to take a plea deal the state was
struggling or I shouldn't say the state
the federal government these are the
feds they almost never lose cases but
they could not get any of these
individuals why antifa wear all black
for a reason it doesn't matter if a cop
actually sees you a cop could see you
you could take your mask off you could
smile and you can wave and when it comes
to the criminal trial the defense will
say what was the defendant wearing it'll
say a black hoodie a black
bandan black jeans with black gloves and
you say he looked at you and smiled
that's right could you have been
mistaken I mean there were 300 people
wearing the exact same thing and the cop
will say no it was him and look at the
journey like do you believe that that he
actually knew who this guy was with
everyone wearing the same thing they
couldn't get him on conspiracy charges
and they couldn't get anyone to believe
that they singled out individuals with
crimes so the entire group in their
organized Act of terrorism at Donald
Trump's inauguration were not only
having their charges dismissed but they
were paid out millions of dollars mhm
and let's not forget the
529 absolutely when they broke down the
barriers outside of the White House and
forced the president of the United
States into a bunker instead of Fire
Bomb the White House grounds that's
right and the media's concern about that
was that Trump was very mean and he used
tear gas so that he could get across the
street and stop them from burning down a
historic church if they just like Danes
was saying earlier they just by talking
to someone you can come up with you know
multiple felonies if the federal
government actually wanted to stop this
kind of stuff they absolutely could I
think this is the key that that you know
for years now we have focused on the
rhetoric of the double standard yeah
live in the logic look at the way look
at the way that the government treats
Trump versus Biden look at the treatment
of antifa versus antifa BLM on the one
hand versus let's say the January 6
protesters on the other now how do you
resolve a double standard because a
double standard usually has a kind of a
hidden premise and the hidden premise
here is that we have a government that
wants to apply the law equitably and if
that is the case then there certainly is
a double standard they're not doing that
but let's remove that assumption let's
assume that you're dealing with an
emerging police state and now it's a
police state but it's we're not North
Korea right if we were North Korea or
China I couldn't make a movie called
police state so we have to be a police
state in the making under construction
if you will and if a police state is
under construction it needs political
allies it needs it would ideally like to
have a whole political party that is in
bed with the police state that's going
to help build it and so the police state
is going to say the police state now
becomes like the family dog notice how
the family dog is really friendly to
members of the family and Barks at
strangers so the family dog is not a
hypocrite the family dog can distinguish
between the pals and strangers and
similarly the police state is friendly
toward the people who are helping to
build the police state even as it is
unly hostile to anybody that it sees as
a threat to the police state and if you
apply the single standard it all makes
sense you don't have a double standard
anymore they're acting consistently it's
a hierarchy absolutely right well you
can also recognize them as the the
militant arm of the the party that's in
power basically and we've seen this
historically Communists have always done
this the Communists did this in Spain
where people who are non-government
officials or weren't necessarily
commissioned to by the government were
going and digging up the dead bodies of
nuns and Priests and displaying them in
churches in order to persecute
Christians and the government just
wouldn't arrest them when they did it
because of course they were perfectly
happy to see them do that and that was
the fact of the matter and that's what
we have in the United States today
antifa and BLM run around burning down
buildings destroying people lives doing
violence against innocent people and
even though they aren't technically
owned or told to do this by the
Democratic party or the political
establishment it allows them to so it's
just the same when people share an
ideology they don't need direct orders
from uh top down Authority if they all
are looking for the essentially the same
result which is to delegitimize the the
fundamental principles that the United
States are has built on if they're
looking for that result all the all the
tactics that they come up with they're
all acceptable Tim's Tim's talked about
uh shared what is it a diversity of TS
Tim talked about that a bunch when you
go to a left left liberal protest where
there's thousands of people you will see
what they they look man these people lie
because in their
worldview lying to accomplish your goal
is fine the ends justify the means and
what you end up with is a wide range
from Li
to far-left extremist tankes and they
all say the same thing respect the
diversity of tactics and I would ask
them what that means and they would say
well not everybody agrees there's one
way to to bring about change so if
someone in that we we may not completely
RI how they're doing things but we're
mostly lined politically we just back
off and let them do their thing I want
to point something out right now uh
October 7th the attack in in uh Israel
that was a diversity of tactics that's
the same exact thing and that's why you
see the left in New York City people
saying they're Freedom Fighters
decolonized This is what people should
should pay attention to not every single
person who is in support of Palestine is
in support of Hamas Fair Point not every
single person who was marching knows
exactly what their with their protesting
but they're all told the same thing by
the organizers to uh to respect the
diversity of tactics it's the phrase
they use now think about what that means
when a guy stands up with a megaphone
and celebrates 5,000 rocket attacks
exploding over Tel Aviv or hitting
uh uh some of these hospitals or
whatever when they cheer for their
resistance Fighters these other liberals
who aren't really don't really know a
lot are told but you have to respect it
and so they may not 100% align but they
don't interfere as these people advocate
for these things here's the important
takeaway you may not care about Israel
Palestine where the United States I
think domestic issues are way more
important totally fair but when you have
people marching alongside pramas
extremists and these people don't care
about Hamas but they're holding up
decolonize signs and clapping for the
Freedom Fighters understand what their
mentality is here in the United States
they would do exactly as Hamas did here
to accomplish their goals 100% to the
point where Hassan perer on his show
said but the but some of those babies
are settlers in reference to the
justification of killing settlers
referencing that babies are also
settlers I'd like to give him the
benefit of the doubt I'd like to but I
think it's very dangerous when a dude
has consistent been in support of like
look when Assan literally says that
Hamas is just morally and legally in the
right to to do these things to reclaim
stolen land and then ads and babies are
settlers I just don't see I don't see
why we should give them the benefit of
the
doubt um we we also you know this is
such an awkward topic because until you
have a firsthand experience it is
difficult to believe now Julie for
example you've sat in on so many trials
right and and we've talked a little bit
about this I mean you you almost feel
like you're living in a surreal America
because you're seeing it and yet it is a
knowledge that is a little
incommunicable uh for me like a turning
point in my whole career was you know if
you would ask me 10 years ago or 15
years ago like what's American politics
in a nutshell I would go well it's like
a debating Society you've got the left
you got the right you have two different
Visions these people value Liberty these
people value equality uh Liberty
equality of of Rights equality of
outcomes and you put these rival Visions
before the American people and the
people choose and sometimes they go this
side sometimes they go that side and
then when I was sitting across from the
lawyers of the Obama doj and I realized
in this conversation I'm having with
these guys that for a trivial offense if
they could have locked me up for 10
years they would have done it and I
realized whoa well that's a wrecking
ball in my whole theory of American po
or even all the guys I knew you know I
lived in DC so it's a small town I knew
EJ Dion at the Washington Post I knew
guys at all the different you know
liberal outlets and I saw these guys in
Trover bookstore I saw them in
restaurants when my case came up they'd
come up to me they be denes man looks
like you're really being shafted and I'd
be like okay EJ well if I'm being
shafted you know Megan Kelly is saying
that on Fox news but it'd be really
helpful if you said that in the
Washington Post because for a liberal to
defend me against Obama H I got that
kind of awkward I can't really do that
and then realize again that this is not
quite the America you thought you were
living in it's become gangsterz no
America politics is America's most
extreme and crazy team sport you have to
be loyal to your side no matter what and
I think that's true on both sides it's
really easy to see where the left locks
down in some ways they're more effective
right they're able to get a lot of young
people to go out and do their bidding by
saying these trigger words and saying
colonizer and then they all know exactly
what side they're against but I also
think that the right does this too where
there are some uh portions of the party
where they say I'm not I'm too afraid to
say anything I mean that was what I
found really interesting about the
freedom caucus right they like all of
these people started saying these are
our values we have American first values
we want to push forward and in and they
gain traction even though the mainstream
RNC was not super comfortable with it
well you know they're being defeated and
it feels pretty good so hearing Kevin
McCarthy elbowed uh brette in the back
I'm like man he's losing it but so be it
the stories that I've heard about the
things they established Republicans have
done to uh good Americans who wanted to
serve this country and sometimes serve
it again this time as as uh public
officers uh good riddance good riddance
to the to to this extremism and
tribalism you know I I'll Circle back a
little bit of the daily wire here
because the thought just occurred to me
that with regard to the Candice business
and that is that daily wire has been out
of sync with Trump right they've been
kind of part of the never Trump or camp
and so on and and they're very
successful company but it's a little
tricky for them as a brand you're a very
successful company but you're out of
sync with the mainstream of the
Republican party so daily wi needs some
magga Spirit uh if only to deflect the
never trumpism that's clearly in in
Daily wire so so Candace actually has a
lot of Leverage because she represents
that she comes in from that kind of Maga
Wing if you will and then daily W can
say as Jeremy boring has said you know
we are open to all different points of
view and so on so and they can ask them
why is her audience loyal to her I mean
it makes them potentially expand their
business model of course exactly that's
my point is that the daily wire there's
always a little bit of a danger that
they go the way of the National Review
yes the National Review dug in on
anti-trump on never Trump would not back
off and pushed out Victor Davis Hansen
who was basically the one
crime Trump guy but and a historian who
knows more than all of them put good
he's brilliant he's great a lot of
people right now are very critical of
the daily wire especially in our chat
but I hope this is worth at least
something uh man when I sit down with
big corporate media companies and
lawyers and I've rejected all of them it
is the most annoying and insulting thing
I've had companies send me contracts
where they're like here's the deal here
want to do I'm like this sounds great we
shake hands they send me a contract
totally the opposite that steals
everything and is destructive and their
response is well hire a lawyer and
Redline it and when I sat down with
Jeremy it was like it was like talking
it was legit and and I really do respect
that I feel bad for him with all this
going on I hope at the end of it there's
no bad blood can is and Ben get along I
hope this resolves itself generates some
press for him it's not just about you
know I know I know them and I don't like
it when people fight but it really is
also about if if we are all in agreement
on 90% of things then come on man if if
the farle can all wear the same clothes
and get away with committing crimes
we're not even anywhere like trying to
advocate for anything close to that
we're just saying guys let's let's focus
on the issues that we need to focus on
and stop tearing each other down well we
want to build a parallel economy and and
to do that and and and we're in a hard
business because people block you you
know you can't advertise on YouTube and
you can't put your ads up on Facebook
and then Walmart won't sell your DVDs so
if you can build a successful company in
with that wind against you you're doing
something right so that's yeah and I
think there are I mean no matter what
happens right now with the daily wire
they have done a lot of really positive
things oh I think we just lost your mic
did you I touched my wire one time uh I
said that the daily wire has done
positive things we don't need a monolith
of every single news organization or you
know alternative Media Company saying
exactly the same thing but they
themselves have to tolerate a little bit
of diversity of thought thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at
timcast.net
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time